bienvenue chers abonnés bienvenue aux
nouveaux si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner vous verrez l'ambiance
c'est très sympa avant de démarrer la
vidéo laissez-moi vous présenter Nord
VPN qui sponsorise aujourd'hui la vidéo
Nord VPN pour les personnes qui ne
connaissent pas c'est un outil de
cybersécurité mais plutôt que de vous
présenter toutes les actions que peut
vous proposer cet outil je vais prendre
deux exemples qui me concernent et qui
peut-être vous parleront on va commencer
par les mots de passe parce que j'ai
très longtemps fait partie de ce groupe
de personnes qui utilisaient tout le
temps le même mot de passe sur tous les
sites oui oui je sais c'est flippant ne
faites pas ça nous sommes en 2023
protégez-vous les gens mais j'avais
absolument aucune inspiration ou envie
de m'occuper de ça donc on délègue cette
tâche direction le pack Nord pass qui
est un ben gestionnaire de mot de passe
justement il fait le boulot à votre
place création de mot de passe fort
surveillance continue et alerte en cas
d'attaque et voilà c'est réglé deuxième
exemple dont je vais vous parler je pars
très très prochainement en vacances
alleluia en Espagne et la question c'est
comment faire pour voir la coup de monde
de rugby ah oui non mais il faut vite
trouver une solution et bien
figurez-vous que la solution c'est Nord
VPN encore une fois ça vous permet de
regarder du contenu français à
l'étranger en Espagne en Grèce au
Grenland que sais-je où vous voulez pour
utiliser Nord VPN vous avez 4 mois
offerts sur tous les abonnements de 2
ans en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche ici que je mets en barre de
description et également au commentaire
épinglé cette offre est garantie
satisfait ou remboursé sous 30 jours
donc c'est sans risque allez-y vous
pouvez essay je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté on enchaîne avec le sujet du
[Musique]
jour avant de démarrer cet épisode j'ai
l'immense joie de vous annoncer la
sortie d'un livre que nous avons écrit
avec Lucas Pacotte en direct de Paris où
nous venons de recevoir et de découvrir
parce qu'on ne l'a jamais vu notre livre
49 petites histoires dans l'histoire de
l'Antiquité si vous avez aimé les format
court les fameux coup dur ce livre
devrait vous plaire parce qu'il reprend
certains des thèmes comme Hannibal
Antoine et Cléopâtre en les développant
si je devais résumer ce livre je vous
dirais que c'est le livre qu'on aurait
aimé avoir en entrant à l'université
avec Lucas donner en peu de mots les
clés d'événements emblématiques et de
thèmes importants de l'histoire antique
en bref se réapproprieré la culture
générale avec ce livre vous ne
confondrai plus jamais le Panthéon et le
Parthénon oui ça arrive même au meilleur
on espère vraiment que ça vous plaira
vous pouvez le trouver dans toutes les
librairies et vous pouvez le commander
là dans le lien qui s'affiche dans le
lien petit i merci on dir que tu fais
ordonnance médicale avec oui truc
laologie ça sera matin midi et soir hein
une histoire le matin une histoire à
midi une histoire le soir puis au bout
de normalement une vingtaine de jours ça
dorait traitement être terminé puis vous
revenez vous nous dites ce que vous en
avez pensé pu on fait le
qu on a déjà parlé ici à plusieurs
reprises de technologie de pointe
appliqué à l'archéologie que ce soit
avec l'intelligence artificiel le ldard
la paléogénétique ou le microscope
électronique à balayage les archéologues
ont aujourd'hui aujourd'hui à leur
disposition des outils qui leur
permettent de déceler des traces
auparavant insoupçonné dans des objets
toujours plus étranges une micro trace
d'outil quelques milligrammes de carbone
ou de collagène d'un os et c'est un
petit bout d'histoire qui apparaît on va
aujourd'hui chercher des informations
archéologiques dans des recoins toujours
plus insoupçonnés parmi ces objets
sondés par les nouvelles techniques
d'analyse il y en a un que je trouve
particulièrement intéressant déjà parce
qu'il révèle des informations capitales
mais aussi parce qu'il parle force à
tout le monde ce sont les dents enfin je
dis ça parle forcément à tout le monde
mais si ça se trouve vous n'avez pas de
dents il y a des gens qui on pas de
dents ici parlez-en moi en commentaire
et parlez-en à votre médecin aussi c'est
important les dents donc quand un
archéologue trouve une dent il est très
content c'est petit c'est joli mais
surtout c'est très solide une dent ça se
conserve très bien les mailles qui
l'entoure avec ses 97 % de matière
minérale et tout simplement la matière
la plus dure du corps humain ça résiste
même au feu c'est pas un hasard si les
enquêteur de la police criminelle se
base sur les empreintes de dents pour
identifier les corps pour les
archéologues s'agit pas de résoudre à un
homicide généralement il y a
prescription mais plutôt d'en apprendre
plus sur la personne à qui appartient la
dent car souvent il y avait quelqu'un au
bout de la dent et comme ce quelqu'un se
servait tout le temps de sa dent elle a
enregistré quantité d'informations sur
lui comme ça sans lui demander un peu
comme les cookies d'un site internet oui
on dit cookie nous ici je sais pas mais
bon là pour une fois c'est pour la bonne
cause grâce à ce fossil prêt à l'emploi
on peut accéder à des détails
incroyables sur les humains des périodes
passées je vous propose donc un aperçu
de trois différentes techniques utilisé
par les archéologues pour lire le passé
dans une dent on sait d'expérience que
les dents susent vous vous souvenez sans
doute que lorsqu'elles ont poussé vos
dents définitives n'étaient pas aussi
lisses qu'aujourd'hui vous les avez usé
avec l'âge l'usure continue et abrasse
parfois les dents jusqu'à la base
plusieurs des dents d'un squelette
fournit donc une bonne estimation de
l'âge d'un individu pour l'archéologue
mais l'usure se manifeste aussi par des
traces beaucoup moins visibles et qui
sont une véritable mine d'information
les micro
[Musique]
traces comme leur nom l'indique ces
traces sont microscopiques elles sont le
résultat de la mastication et de tous
les microtraumatismes infligés aux dents
enregistrés pour toujours à la surface
de l'émail il faut donc des outils
extrêmement développés pour les décelés
que ce soit des microscopes
électroniques à balayage ou des
algorithmes informatiques d'analyse
fractale pour reconstituer à différentes
échelles la complexité de la surface une
fois l'observation réalisée on obtient
une modélisation extrêmement fine de la
surface d'une dents mais il faut encore
mettre au point un référentiel
expérimental pour l'interpréter
correctement il faut en fait récolter
des dents qui ont été exposées pendant
toute une vie à certaines conditions
connues pour ensuite les comparer aux
exemplaires archéologiques si on a les
mêmes même type de trace sur les dents
expérimentales et les dents
archéologiques c'est donc qu'elles ont
dû être utilisées de la même manière
cette technique d'investigation a été
utilisé notamment pour des périodes très
anciennes les paléontologues qui
s'intéressent aux hinidé ont en effet
assez peu d'osement à leur disposition
et souvent tout ce qu'il y a à se mettre
sous la dent ce sont des dents justement
la forme des dents est déjà une
information précieuse en soi puisqu'elle
renseigne sur le régime alimentaire de
l'espèce ou du moins sur la manière dont
elle broit sa nourriture mais les
microtraes à apporte des nuances
supplémentaires les paléontologues ont
pu comparer les traces d'usure sur les
dents fossiles avec celles de primates
actuells en fonction de l'usage qu'ils
en font consommation de feuilles et de
fruits mais aussi arrachage d'écorces
ouverture de coque de noix c'est leur
référentiel ensuite ils ont analyser des
dents d'australopythèque et de
paranthrope deux espèces de préhumains
qui vivaient en Afrique australe et
orientale il y a entre 4 et 2 millions
d'années ils ont pu constater qu'aucun
modèle de microtraace parmi les primates
actuels n'était similaire aux traces
observé sur les omnidés fossiles ils en
ont conclu que ces anciens omnidés
n'utilisaient pas leurs dents de la même
façon que les singes actuels les
parentthrop avec leurs puissantes
mâchoires et leurs dents plates qu'on
pensait destiné à casser des fruits à
coq aurait pu les utiliser plutôt à la
manière d'une meule pour broyer une
nourriture moins dure mais très abrasive
un peu comme le fait le panda avec son
bambou ces analyses remettent en cause
ce qu'on croyait savoir de
l'alimentation des premiers omnidés dans
la suite de l'histoire humaine les MICR
trat sur les dents montre clairement le
passage d'une économie de
chassecueillette à une économie agricole
les dentsusent d'une manière
caractéristique poli par une grande
consommation de céréales elles sont
aussi couvertes de traces causées par
l'utilisation des meules celles-ci
laissent des petits grains de pierre
dans la farine qui participent à
l'abrasion de l'émail et grave
littéralement des sillons à sa surface
ajouter à cela que les céréales sont
riches en sucre et que le dentifrice
n'existeit pas encore et vous obtenez de
très belles caries néolithiques enfin
les MICR traces sur les dents ne
renseignent pas que sur les aliments
consommés mais aussi sur la manière dont
ils étaient préparés au Proche Orient
l'apparition de la céramique environ 2
millénaires après les débuts de
l'agriculture fait changer l'aspect des
microtraaces dentaires les céréales sont
désormais moins consommées en galettes
mais davantage en bouillie cuites dans
des pots en céramique résultat moins de
mastication moins d'usure moins de
traces les aliments n'ont pas
fondamentalement changé mais des
techniques de préparation sont apparu et
tout ça on le voit grâce aux
dents
après les caris on reste dans le glamour
voici venu le tartre le tartre dentaire
est déposé par la salive à la surface
des dents c'est un mélange de composés
minéraux comme le carbonate de calcium
et de restes organiquees comme les
bactéries alors c'est pas très ragûtant
je vous le concède mais ça apporte des
informations capitales sur
l'alimentation parce que dans ce dépôt à
la surface des dents sont piégés de
nombreux microrestes notamment les
phyolyites les les phyolites ce sont des
formes de concrétion siliceuse qui se
forment pendant la vie d'une plante et
dont la forme parfois très
caractéristique peut nous renseigner sur
l'espèce qui l'a produite en bref ce
sont des petits fragments de plantes
suffisamment solides et suffisamment
reconnaissables pour qu'on puisse
deviner plusieurs millénair après à
quelle plante ils appartenaient et ça on
aime bien en regardant le tartre sur les
dents fossiles au microscope on peut
donc obtenir de nombreux indices sur
l'alimentation des individus par exemple
l'analyse du tartre dentaire de trois
néoner en daté entre 50000 et 36000 ans
réalisé par Amanda Henry Alison Brooks
et Dolores Piperno a complètement
renouvelé ce qu'on pensait de
l'alimentation au Paléolitique moyen ces
trois archéologues ont montré grâce à
l'étude du tartre dentaire que notre
cousin nandertal consommait déjà des
céréales sauvages pour les
Néandertaliens du site de Shanidar en
Irak qu'elles ont étudié ce sont
notamment des grains d'amidon d'orge qui
ont pu être retrouvés on voit en haut
les exemplaires archéologiques comparés
en bas aux exemplaires modernes le
fragment C à droite correspond à de
l'amidon cuit peut-être bouilli d'autres
fragments qui n'ont pas pu être
déterminés aussi précisément évoquent
des légumineuse comme la lentille plus
surprenant les archéologues ont aussi
trouvé des phyoites de palmiers d'tier
et pour le néandertalien du site de spi
en Belgique elles ont trouvé des grains
d'amidon de plantes proches du sorgo
notamment cette étude montre que
l'alimentation au paléollytique moyen
n'était pas comme on le pense souvent
composé que de viande elle illustre bien
que Néandertal n'était pas moins
efficace que sapience pour exploiter les
différentes sources de calories de son
environnement un argument parfois avancé
pour expliquer sa disparition de quoi
pas mal nuancé aussi le fameux régime
paléo en fait on connaissait déjà des
exemples de restes végétaux dans les
sites Néandertaliens mais il n'y avait
jamais la certitude qu'ils avaient été
consommés parfois des indices très forts
existaient comme lorsqu'on mettait la
main sur des restes de gland ou de
pistache carbonisé dans un lieu de vie
des reste de plantes sur des pierres
utilisées comme Meul évoquai aussi
clairement l'alimentation végétale mais
certains contesté toujours que
Néandertal a pu manger autre chose que
de la bidoche la preuve ultime provient
bien de ce dépôt de tartre qui piège les
microfragment d'aliments bien protégés
sous une couche minéralisée et qui
parvient jusqu'à nous blé lentille date
on n'est pas loin du 5 fruits et légumes
par jour comme quoi se laver les dents
n'êt pas forcément à la recherche mais
lavez-vous les dents quand
[Musique]
même
la troisième technique dont je veux
parler est sans doute la plus
prometteuse en terme de résultat c'est
une méthode qui se développe depuis une
trentaine d'années et qui consiste à
étudier les proportions de certains
isotopes dans une temp pour rappel un
isotope c'est une version un peu
différente d'un atome qui n'a pas le
même nombre de neutrons qu'en temps
normal par exemple l'atome d'oxygène a
normalement 8 protons et 8 neutrons on
l'appelle l'oxygène 16 mais il y a aussi
de l'oxygène 17 avec un neutron en plus
et de l'oxygène 18 avec 2 neutrons en
plus certains de ces isotopes sont
instables c'est-à-dire qu'ils se
désintègrent avec le temps c'est ce qui
permet de faire des datations au carbone
14 par exemple mais il y a aussi des
isotopes stables qui perdurent tout à
fait normalement et c'est cela qui nous
intéressent pour les dents dans l'émail
des dents qui est un phosphate de
calcium on peut mesurer les rapports
entre le carbone 12 et 13 l'oxygène 16
et 18 ou bien le strontium 86 et 87 ces
atomes sont intégrés à la dent au moment
de la croiss sens et renseigne donc sur
la jeunesse de l'individu à l'âge adulte
la minéralisation de la dent est
terminée et elle n'accumule plus de
matière contrairement aux EAU dont la
composition se renouvelle au fur et à
mesure de l'existence et comme l'émail
est très peu sujet aux contaminations
postmortem par l'environnement c'est
donc une excellente fenêtre sur le mode
de vie de l'individu puisque certains
isotopes sont plus présents dans
certains milieux tels que les milieux
marins ou les massifs granitiques ça
ouvre des perspectives très
intéressantes en étudiant la proportion
de certains isotopes contenu dans une
dent on peut donc dcellerer des indices
sur l'environnement dans lequel ont
évolué les êtres vivants avant d'en
donner quelques exemples il faut
préciser que l'analyse du rapport des
isotopes est un processus très complexe
qui demande des manipulations très
précises et des instruments de haute
technologie comme des spectromètres de
masse les données collectées doivent
ensuite être interprétées grâce à des
référentiels patiamment élaboré c'est
donc encore une fois la pointe de la
recherche je tiens à le préciser parce
que on s'en rend pas forcément compte
quand on livre là comme ça directement
les résultats et les interprétations
mais franchement ça demande des années
de boulot ces analyses isotopiques des
dents ont notamment été utilisés sur les
animaux domestiques pour documenter les
pratiques d'élevage sur le site de Bercy
au bord de la scène et qui date du
néoitique Moyen en plus de magnifiques
pirogues monoxy que vous pouvez admirer
au musée carnavaletis de nombreux restes
de beauvin ont été retrouvé l'analyse
des isotopes d'oxygène dans les dents
des jeunes beauvin du site donne des
indices sur la saison des naissances et
les techniques d'élevage car la quantité
d'oxygène 18 fixée dans les dents dépend
de la température de l'eau bu par
l'animal elle varie donc selon les
saisons et les archéologues parviennent
comme cela à estimer la saison de
naissance des animaux à Bercy cette
analyse a montré que les naissance
n'avait pas toute lieu au même moment
mais s'étalait sur 6 mois d'année
puisqu'il s'agissait pour beaucoup de
veau abattu post lactation c'est-à-dire
garder en vie juste assez longtemps pour
stimuler la descente de l'IDE de leur
mère cela témoigne d'une volonté des
éleveurs la lactation des vaches devait
durer entre 6 et 7 mois et en espaçant
les naissances cela permettait aux
éleveurs d'avoir du lait toute l'année
la production de lait est d'ailleurs
attestée par les résidus au fond des
poteries désormais on sait qu'il
s'agissait d'un vrai choix d'une
spécialisation économique plus au nord
dans les îles Orcades au large de
l'Écosse les isotopes de l'oxygène sont
complétés par ceux du carbone pour nous
renseigner sur l'élevage néolithique le
climat très rigoureux de cet archipel a
contraint les éleveurs du 3è millénaire
avant Jésus-Christ a adopté des
stratégies originales la comparaison
avec des dents de mouton modernes dont
on connaît l'alimentation a permis
d'obtenir des résultats intéressants les
moutons néolithiques de l'île de Holm of
papa se nourrissaient d'algu les taux
d'oxygène 18 ont même suggéré qu'il
devaient s'agir d'algues fraîches et non
pas séché et stocké par les éleveurs ça
signifie qu'elles étaient spontanément
consommées par les moutons laissé en
libre paturage sur le littoral et il
existe d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une race
de moutons endémique des Orcades qui se
nourrit presque exclusivement d'algues
leur métabolisme a évolué pour supporter
les grandes quantités de sel et
d'arsenic que ça implique on peut donc
faire remonter cette habitude au moins
au 3e millénaire avant Jésus-Christ
grâce aux analyses isotopiques mais bien
entendu cette technique d'analyse peut
aussi être appliquée aux humains et il y
a un cas vraiment emblématique que je
voudrais développer maintenant c'est
celui de la colonisation de l'Islande
l'Islande c'est une étude de cas idéal
déjà parce que le territoire a été
peuplé intégralement au Moyen-Âge même
si on connaît quelques pièces romaines
qui indiqueent que des marins de
l'antiquité s'y sont peut-être échoués
surtout l'Islande a une géologie tout à
fait exceptionnelle c'est une terre
volcanique qui est sortie de l'océan
Atlantique récemment dans les 25
derniers millions d'années et qui
présentent donc des niveaux de strontium
87 très bas je m'explique le strontium
87 se forme par désintégration
radioactive d'un autre élément le
rubidium 87 cette désintégration prend
beaucoup de temps et c'est pourquoi on
trouve davantage de strontium 87 dans
les vieilles formation géologique comme
les massifs granitiques que dans les
régions volcaniques bien plus jeunes ce
strontium entre dans l'écosystème par
altération des roches passe dans le sol
puis par les végétaux dans la chaîne
alimentaire il se substitue parfois au
calcium dans les dents et se retrouve
piégé dans les mailles le strontium
présent dans les dents est donc
directement lié au terrain géologique en
mesurant les niveaux de strontium 87
dans les dents d'un individu et en les
comparant à celui de la géologie locale
on peut donc estimer si la personne a
grandi sur place ou pas avec les trois
molaires d'un squelette on peut même
reconstituer les mouvements pendant
toute la jeunesse d'un individu la
première molaire se forme très tôt et
renseigne donc sur la petite enfance la
deuxième molaire est plus tardive et la
troisième qu'on appelle la dent de
sagesse renseigne sur le début de l'âge
adulte avec tout ça en tête les
archéologues Douglas Price et ILD dur
Guess de tir ont analysé 90 squelettes
pour sonder l'origine géographique des
premiers colons de l' Islande à partir
du 9e siècle après Jésus-Christ pour
mieux voir les phénomènes de migration
ils nont sélectionné que des adultes les
chroniqueurs islandais du 13e siècle
mentionne que les colons qui ont peuplé
le pays provenaient majoritairement de
Norvège mais aussi des îles britanniques
des territoires géologiquement bien plus
vieux que l'Islande et qui devrait faire
apparaître des niveaux de strontium 87
très haut chez les individus les
différences de valeur entre ces
individus suggèent aussi des provenances
différentes les résultats montrent une
relative homo hogénéité du corpus à
l'exception de quelques individus qui
apparaissent à droite de ce graphique
leur taux de strontium 87 clairement
plus élevé indique qu'ils n'ont pas
grandi en Islande mais qu'ils y ont
migré à l'âge adulte après que leur dent
a fini de grandir les différences de
valeur entre ces individus suggèrent
aussi des provenances différentes pour
savoir qui a grandi en Islande et qui
est arrivé à l'âge adulte il faut se
baser sur le niveau moyen de strontium
87 dans l'océan puisque le ratio moyen
des sols islandais est très bas compris
entre 0,703 et 0,704 il ne peut de toute
façon pas y avoir de ratio supérieur à
celui de l'océan pour un islandais
c'est-à-dire
0,792 un islandais qui toute sa vie ne
mangerait que du poisson ne pourrait pas
dépasser
0,792 tous les individus ayant un ratio
supérieur à ce seuil océanique sont donc
forcément des immigrants dans cette
étude cela correspond à 13 individus 7
hommes 5 femmes et un on sait pas et il
se trouve que sur ces 13 individus 12
d'entre eux sont datés de la première
période d'occupation de l'île on aurait
donc bien là un témoin de ce mouvement
de colonisation de l'île au Moyen-Âge
cette étude montre au passage que ces
nouveaux venus ont débarqué dans deux
zones différentes la côte sud et l'ya
fiordure en fjord au nord de l'île de
quoi lancer une étude de la première
occupation du territoire ce que fait
ressortir cette étude c'est aussi le
régime alimentaire des Islandais on l'a
dit le niveau de strontium 87 en Islande
est très bas or tous les individus
mesurés sont bien au-dessus des niveaux
géologiques en supposant qu'ils sont nés
sur place ça signifie qu'ils ont trouvé
tout ce strontium dans les produits de
la mer contrairement à une idée
largement répandue le Viking se nourrit
exclusivement de fruits de mer ce qui ne
l'empêche pas de rester très humain
cette orientation vers un régime
alimentaire très marin est aussi
documentée au Groenland qui était
également peuplé par les Nordiques à
l'époque avec la détérioration du climat
à la fin du Moyen-Âge qu'on appelle le
petit âge glaciaire on constate que les
colons groenlandais abandonne petit à
petit les ressources terrestres de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage pour se
tourner vers les ressources maritimes
plus accessibles peut-être qu'un tel
phénomène a aussi joué en Islande on
peut aussi penser qu'en Islande la
distance par rapport à la côte influe
sur le taux de strontium 97 les
archéologues ont pu montrer que les
sépultures proches du littoral avaient
souvent un niveau de strontium 87 assez
élevé on aurait bien là une signature de
l'alimentation marine c'est
particulièrement clair pour la période
chrétienne le cimetière chrétien
afiardara situé sur la côte montre
uniquement des individus avec des
régimes alimentaires marins au contraire
celui situé à l'intérieur des terres
scellia càdire révèle une diversité de
profil et une nette domination de
l'alimentation d'origine terrestre
origine alimentation mode de vie tout ça
en comptant combien de neutrons ont
certains atomes avouer que c'est quand
même pas mal pour la suite une
comparaison entre ses dents et le
collagène de l'os apportera encore des
précisions Carlos renouvelle sa
composition à l'â Jadu adulte on l'a dit
donc si laadent montre une origine
étrangère mais pas l'os c'est qu'on a
affaire à un migrant de longue date
laadent aura enregistré les premières
années à l'étranger mais l'os montrera
que l'individu a quand même passé
beaucoup de temps en Islande en cumulant
ça avec des datations au carbon 14 on
est plus très loin du passeport complet
avec des tampons d'entrée et de sortie
du territoire voilà il y aura encore de
nombreux exemples fascinants à détailler
comme la possibilité de dater la
révolution néolithique en Amérique du
Nord grâce à la signature isotopique du
maïs dans les dents des agriculteurs ou
les phénomènes de mariage à longue
distance pendant l'Âge du Fer européen
mais on va s'arrêter là je crois que
vous avez saisi l'idée les dents sont de
véritables cartes d'identité
archéologique à condition de savoir
comment les lire merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo merci à toute mon équipe
David a aux illustrations et mootion
design Julien Michel au cadre et au son
Lucas de Levau au montage et Lucas
Pacotte à l'écriture C épisodes sont à
votre disposition et si vous les avez av
manqué les liens sont en barre
d'information merci aux CNC talent pour
leur soutien la chaîne a plus que jamais
besoin de vous si vous le pouvez
n'hésitez pas à faire un don sur l'une
de ces plateformes Kiss Kiss Bank Bank
tipi ou Paypal je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]
salut